[Applause]
yes yes yes
yes that's
right it's Friday so you know what that
means let's welcome tonight's guest he's
here on a day pass from the halfway
house founder of the lofas party.com
Michael
lofas she's my third favorite Charlie
after CHL and horse out kick host
Charlie
[Applause]
Arnold she loves pranks giving thanks
and getting restraining orders CU of
your cousin Hank New York Times
bestselling author and FX contributor
[Applause]
cat and the only thing he hates more
than snow is child support New York
Times best-selling author comedian and
World Champion NWA
[Applause]
whatever
all right this audience is out of
control but before we get to some new
stories let's do
this Greg's
leftovers yeah M you know what it's
where I read the jokes we didn't use
this week that's why they're called
leftovers and as always it's my first
time reading them so if they suck we'll
take Joe Macky on a helicopter ride and
drop him into a
volcano all right Southwest a lines is
being praised by plus-size Travelers
that allow overweight customers a an a
free extra seat as an inflight
meal Ikea is holding a holiday contest
where they will give away 30 giant
meatballs the size of a turkey it weighs
10 PBS and takes four to six weeks to
assemble in response one happy customer
replied put me down for a
doen
a in a recent TV interview Hugh Grant
said he won't do romcoms anymore
claiming he's too old and fat and ugly
nonsense he just needs to be paired with
the right
co-star photos uh show sparse attendance
for a Dylan mulany event at Penn date
apparently tickets ticket sales suffered
when students realized it was for Dylan
Mulaney students are calling Hillary
Clinton's Columbia University class a
huge disappointment but it hasn't
stopped bill from holding office hours
under his
desk researchers in England have an
earth and ancient creature that's
stalked the waters off England's Coast
millions of years ago and had a 6foot
skull or as John Carrey calls it
Dad McDonald's has reintroduced McNugget
Buddies six collectable characters that
come with your happy meal and just like
McNuggets they're also not made of
chicken according to a story in the
Bangkok post a local man escaped prison
hours after surgery to repair his
botched penis
enlargement police say to be on the
lookout for a man with a giant penis
with a file in
[Laughter]
it remember how file was in every prison
escape put it in a cake all right
California could soon vote on recycling
used toilet and bath water for drinking
purposes big whoop we've been doing that
forever said dogs
trains at Newark Penn Station were
delayed on Thursday after a wild bull
ran on the tracks to be fair the bull
took a shortcut since it was late for
[Applause]
work images went viral after
firefighters hoisted a cow out of a
waste fi cess pit in England luckily
they were able to transport it in time
for work
never gets old an anti-aging drug for
dogs has moved closer to gaining FDA
approval customers are already waiting
in
line no it's nothing personal we just
save money using the same picture three
times an Indiana high school student won
a major national award for creating an
app that that helps users find nearby
bathrooms who needs that when you have
pants said one
[Applause]
man a drunken Florida man was arrested
after he sexually molested a manate
mannequin inside a restaurant when asked
about it he said hey I was drunk I
didn't realize it was a
mannequin thank you
thank
you you should have enjoyed that
more according to Facebook December 11th
is the day that most couples break up to
avoid buying Christmas gifts you know
that reminds me it must suck to be Jesus
I mean having your birthday and
Christmas on the same
day reports claim that next year
National TV station will debut the first
ever artificially generated news anchor
which is weird because at Fox we already
have
[Applause]
one yeah in your face Jesse finally a
new study finds that being too
optimistic causes people to make poorer
financial decisions and in some cases it
can lead to
homelessness
now to the
news dancing buffoons who support
Marxist goons true the only thing worse
than their political stances is how this
vomit inducing group dances but now you
probably gouge your eyes out after
seeing this bizarre interpretation of
the Nutcracker inside the White House
but
watch
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
well at least we know all that cocaine
in the West Wing has been put to good
use the crazy part is it was paid for
with everybody's tax dollars except of
course Hunter because he's a tax sheet
apparently Dr Jill invited the Doren
dance troop to perform the Beloved
Christmas classic she originally asked
antifa but they were already booked for
comma Christmas
party
stop after all it was their turn to bail
her
out it was worth it but their dance
moves aren't the only thing that's
nausea inducing turns out the studio is
anti- police and promotes Marxist
organizations like BLM who would have
thought the company's founder Michelle
Dorrance promotes her so called anti-rac
ideology and talks about understanding
her white privilege and the never-ending
struggle against systemic racism and
white supremacy in this country yep
turns out their definition of Nutcracker
is cracking the nuts of
crackers even eboner screw is calling
this broad a buzz kill and if you check
out their website you'll find an entire
page dedicated to links to Banning
prisons BLM protests and organizations
that wanted to fund the police and sadly
not a single Kick-Ass recipe for
peppermint
bark and yet Dr Jill invited them to
perform in America's house during the
most holy time of the year perhaps
because Hamas was
busy but at this point it's to be
expected if the North Pole had a
national anthe anthem they' kneel I
can't wait to see the nativity scene
Rachel LaVine will make an amazing
Virgin
[Music]
Mary you know LOF this I this is just
too easy it's like this whole thing was
created out of a lab for Fox and Friends
to go
crazy but I don't know I mean you're a
homeless non-binary
lesbian do you support the White House
bringing in this woke dance group I
support them shining a light on just the
total insanity that is the Modern Age
like like Joe and Jill now are the crazy
guest stars on the great sitcom of
America you know like the wacky Aunt
would always come in for an episode and
she'd be like you should hug it out and
dance your way out of jams you know and
it turns out her life is a tragedy
that's what this is like Joe and Jill
their lives are suck the kids of
freaking addict they can't do anything
and then they they ruin Christmas with
this horrible Hunger Game it's like a
slow driveby of Christmas yeah and and
the costumes look like it was from a
furniture repair shop yeah you know how
many orgasms did Jill have when she saw
that oh I'm going to wear that I'm going
to wear that tomorrow the big flower on
my head and a couch print it made me
seasick watching it you know like kind
of like a little motion sickness it was
about as Christmas themed as a drag
queen throwing up on a Piata yeah it was
very concerning I was like are they
dancing or having seizures yes uh but
truly I think forget the crimes forget
the Corruptions this display alone
should be enough to get Joe Biden
impeached yes it was that bad uh
somebody's going to clip that out and
think we're
serious gfell CH says Biden should be
impeached over
holiday uh theme part we already know
who's going to call me out for right
there there's there's one name that
sticks out to us we' talked about it for
several weeks on the show uh but but
really there's only one thing that
probably would have made it even more
disturbing that would be zilinsky in the
middle of it all in a unitar gy rating
which of course thanks to the internet
we have already seen yeah that's true
but to like what you said it just sheds
the light on on the bigger problem this
country the government they're doing
everything that they possibly can to
destroy tradition in the name of Dei and
dotopia nonsense and honestly it was
like Whoville on cocaine perfect for the
modern day White House oille on cocaine
yeah and how do you even find an
anti-cop Dance Company I don't know like
you know ball step ball step I can't
breathe ball chain ball CH hands up
don't
shoot cat do you know I just stepping
back this kind of for me anyway reflects
like the the problem with like musical
theater and dance troops it's not
entertainment for you it's entertainment
for the participants it's like a
celebration of ego look at me look at us
that's why that guy was like going like
this and it it's not there's no skill in
that I don't know Greg you're nailing it
you're you're nailing it that was a
brilliant reinterpretation of Hamlet uh
more Motion in your face you're almost
there maybe I'm focusing on the wrong
thing but I feel like I can't be the
only one who doesn't understand why the
executive branch of our government needs
a dance
team like at all right I mean there's
people struggling it's the holiday
struggling to pay for things our
government insists that they can't ease
the tax burden on us at all they can't
find anywhere to make cuts no one was
like what about the White House's dance
team yes I I just think it's so I mean
this is a video for all us to see this a
priority so weird to me that as Citizens
we are forced to give our money to pay
for our own ruler promotional materials
yes it's absurd and it's wrong it is no
that's the worst part about it actually
you know you're right it's like people
are struggling paying their bills and
this is and they expect you to like this
if you criticize this it's on you right
I think it sucks
who did you who do you think Tyrus
picked this who did the vetting do you
think it was really Dr Jill no it wasn't
Greg
no so a lot of you don't know this I
know I've had a lot of jobs but one of
my dreams was to be a choreographer
and the White House came to me and they
said listen I know we don't agree on
much but we agree on One Thing dance
cures everything and I just so happened
to have a script I had been working
on yes and this is it how dare you
gutfield
your greatest life's work I mean this
you know what it was for me Greg it was
all for me no okay we why are we
surprised this is the move big Pharma
every
medical new drug that comes
out they have it with dancing that's
true everything's dancing the world's
falling the but guess what we're dancing
so no one's really mad OIC right yeah
type two diabetes right she's dancing
her little chunky ass off right here's
the C hold on no not yet not yet you
going to wait for this one you want
something to quote I'll get you off the
hook right now if her little ass was
dancing all the time she wouldn't need
the O put that out
there she the one who's you talking
about the one who's lowering her A1
see six outfit changes each one gets
brighter you it's everything like they
just they just bring dances in they can
literally tell us listen China just
bought half of
America I'm not going to lie I've said
it about her as
well all right we got to move on hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else